i'd like this quick take to adopt the
form
of what is called a pep talk now if
you're not familiar
with a pep talk because i think that's
kind of an american
idea it's a short talk that's supposed
to
get people feeling better to get them
kind of jazzed up to
help them to resolve to do
something and and the topic that i'm
going to talk about here
is one that i think a lot of people can
in fact use
a pep talk on especially when it comes
to
philosophy so a lot of my students
quite a few lifelong learners will
express
sentiments of feeling intimidated that's
the word that one person used
recently when approaching philosophical
works and this can extend more broadly
to
classic works of literature and all
sorts of other things
and the idea is there's this feeling
that comes with it that might
hold a person back from actually
engaging
with those works and we could use other
similar
feelings like fear or anxiety
a sense of perhaps even shame or guilt
or embarrassment that modality
of emotion a kind of reticence
that stands in the way of cracking open
the book
and starting on the path and adventure
of reading and this can indeed apply to
a lot of works it came up
in relation to the brothers karamazov
which is a very philosophical piece
of literature by theodore dostoevsky who
many people
consider to be you know one of the
greatest of russian writers so
you can see the bar is set pretty high
and that can promote a sense of you know
not feeling at
ease in going about studying these texts
and i i actually solicited
some you know ideas about what people
feel anxious or reticent or intimidated
about
i'm also drawing on my own experience
having taught students
for more than 20 years now and having
been a student myself
and so there's a number of common themes
that
come up and i'm just going to run
through them and you might find yourself
relating to these so people ask
themselves when they're approaching a
work of philosophy like you know
kant's critique of pure reason or rene
descartes meditations on first
philosophy
am i smart enough do do i have what it
takes or am i
not smart enough to be able to get
anything
out of the work and there's there's a
closely related
worry as well what if other people who
are clearly getting something out of
this work what if i can't
keep up with them what if i'm not having
the same kind of insights as they are
you know there's other worries about
these these works having
technical terminology what do all these
words mean
am i going to be able to wade through
them or
having a complex structure whether at
the level of the paragraph
or the chapter or the book itself
and you know there's also this worry oh
man these thoughts are really
deep am i be will i be able to get them
am i
the kind of person who can make sense
out of these things
there's also concerns about you know
maybe there's a whole background that i
need to know before i jump into these so
that i'll get something
out of it there's others
who express concerns like am i supposed
to understand this
all right away if i don't understand it
right away
then is there something wrong with me
how can i proceed if i don't understand
the first parts of what i'm reading do i
have to stay there until i
understand it before i move on to the
next
there's also concerns about not
understanding all these matters as
quickly as other students at least
appear to be
understanding it and you know there's
also
a worry maybe i'll understand things but
i'll actually understand it wrong i'll
get things
mixed up i'll misunderstand things and
i'll damage my
my mind or my progress pick whatever you
want these
these are all legitimate concerns in
some ways but in other ways
they're the sort of thing that i think
if you pick it and and you
question you'll find some of these going
away so if these are things that have
been hitting you
you know the first thing i want to say
is hey that's okay
a lot of people go through that
including myself i've
you know when i'm approaching something
that's way
out of my field philosophy is a very
vast
set of disciplines you know i might feel
some of these concerns myself but we
don't have to allow ourselves
to be you could say disabled or
guided by these one thing i do want to
say
is that i think a lot of people or at
least i suspect a lot of people
probably have these worries
weighing on them in part because of
their past experiences
and some of those past experiences could
have been you know reading a book and
not understanding it and feeling kind of
foolish or stupid or not as good as
other people as a result but i think a
lot of it comes from negative
experiences with
other people like teachers for example
saying what's wrong with you can't you
get this you know
and very often it's it's a sign of a bad
teacher
or you know having um social critics
or opinion formers tell us how wonderful
these books are particularly people from
the elites who had the opportunity to
study with private tutors
and you know have the confidence
building things in their life
allowing them to have that sort of sense
by the way
i'll tell you one thing elites don't
understand these books any better than
anybody else does
or it could be your own peers you know
particularly if you're
in an intellectual group there's
sometimes like jockeying for position
and people talking a lot of smack at
each other
you know i mean i i don't know how many
times i've seen people in
in various forums criticize each other
for not understanding hegel when none of
them under actually understand
hegel and they're just making each other
kind of feel bad and posturing sort of
like virgins who you know
talk about their sexual experiences that
they've never actually
had so you know if that's been the case
then you know
when you hear these voices arising
realize that they have an origin
and push them aside
the result of these these worries
can sometimes be that people won't read
texts at all
or they'll wait until the last minute
because they're so anxious about not
screwing it up and then they try to
blaze their way through the text
and it doesn't it doesn't come off well
so
you know sometimes people don't read the
text or they don't allow themselves
enough time to read them
or they do so and they feel crappy while
they're doing it because they're always
worried when's the next shoe going to
drop
something's going to happen i don't
understand and it takes away a lot of
joy
and it takes away a lot of excitement
and engagement that should be there for
you
as you're reading great works of
philosophical literature when you're
reading plato's symposium
or descartes meditations or mary
wollstonecraft's
vindication of the rights of women there
it's going to be difficult but there
should also be something in you
responding that that you know is a kind
of joy
and if that doesn't happen right away
that's okay it doesn't have to happen
right away that's another kind of
pressure you can take off your shoulders
so what can you do i'm going to give you
a couple of
pointers that might be useful for some
of you this is part of the pep talk
you know take the pressure off of
yourself you don't have to understand
everything right away you're okay you're
doing good
by putting yourself into it just like
the person who goes to the gym
you know they're not going to bench 450
right away or
press whatever they're going to do on
the leg press they have to work at it
and that's that's perfectly
normal going to the gym putting in the
time
that's the thing that really matters
if you find yourself engaging in
negative self-talk and
running yourself down talk back to that
say well how do you know that i don't
understand things
how do you know that i'm never going to
really make any sense of this
talk back to your inner voice because
your inner voice
it's not the the you know the oracle or
something like that
and you can also tell yourself that
it's okay that you do feel intimidated
or you know
anxious that's that's fine lots of
people feel that way
you don't have to allow that to control
you you
can read the works whether you
feel a certain way or not and your
feelings don't have to dominate you
remind yourself as well if you are
feeling these things that this is this
is natural and normal
it's just like approaching any other
thing you're going to learn an
instrument you're going to learn a
language
you're going to go into a very different
social setting you're gonna feel a
little bit
out of sorts but if you spend some time
there
and you get your you know get your
footing as we say you'll start to feel
better about it and you will be able to
learn something and understand something
and get something out of
the texts so the last thing that i want
to say and this is sort of the
ra ra pep thing is if you've got a work
a book that you have been leaving on the
shelf
and not opening up because you know
you're worried about
whether you can actually understand it
crack it open
what's the worst that can happen right
you start reading it
and it's you know eagles phenomenology
of spirit and you're confused
you're like everybody else and that's
okay just you know
keep working at it persevere keep coming
back to it
and you are capable of understanding
something nobody when it comes to these
great works of classic literature
nobody gets everything that's going on
the first time or
the tenth time or even the hundredth
time i don't know how many times
i've read through and even taught some
of these works and i find something new
quite often coming back to them myself
and i do so in conversation
with others where they're also surprised
as well so
take a little pressure off yourself and
go ahead and try
you are capable of studying philosophy
you